a brewery in western ukraine is
determined to help defend the nation
against russian aggression with
well an alternative kind of cocktail
usually the producers of craft beers the
brewers are now contributing to the war
effort here by producing molotov
cocktails
in their bottles joining me now as the
owner of the pravda brewery yuri
zastavny thank you very much
for being with us yuri and i see you're
in your brewery there you've effectively
joined the resistance
well uh we never left the resistance you
know uh west ukraine where we are has a
long history of fighting uh the russians
since
uh 1939.
and talking about the situation now you
there is a high time in uh everyone's
life when you really have
uh to mobilize yourself to use all your
knowledge all your energy
everything you've lived for and
everything you live you've gained in
life to turn it into
making
the fall of this empire possible making
the future of your kids better and this
is what we do
we collected that we put together our
own money
and we started to
we actually we built on our knowledge of
chemistry and our experience from 2014
maidan revolution to make good quality
molotov cocktails
and this is about the time when you have
to do what you
can do
and even more when you have to do this
so i mean you so locals are coming to
help you your workers are helping you
and you're producing what how many
molotov cocktails a day are you
producing
uh well we've only been doing this for
uh three days because uh the war is
actually like a hundred plus hours yeah
so we it's not a it's not an established
operation in a way yeah first day we we
did three to four hundred next day we
did more so far we had a small break
because uh we've stocked we've stocked
the road blocks that that require them
part of them go to kiev but it's not a
very transportable thing so we we make
them as um as the need comes um and we
have a flood of people who want to
donate money for this we we're
collecting local currency we're
collecting collecting euros and us
dollars to our accounts
and people actually bring us empty
bottles use machinery oil magnesium
powder and everything
and then we use our own
labor in a safe way because we know how
to do it in a in a safe way because we
are in that kind of food production um
and
we are renewing this effort
actually today
you're up against though yuri just
finally you're up against
you know a very powerful military force
um
it's the time
when it's now or never
the
russian enemy which who came to our land
has to stop and we will do everything
all ukrainians women men
all ages all social statuses they all
are everybody is making everything
possible for this to stop and to really
turn the situation around we have
already disrupted the plans of the
dictator to uh to have a blitzkrieg
and that's already a good win now we
have to continue fighting we are doing
it not only for us we are also doing it
for europe and we are doing for the we
are doing it for the whole world because
it's really the base human things that
underline this there is no other way to
do we must be winning this war